why we have the politicians we
have it's become the boring truism of
British politics to suggest that the
caliber of our political Representatives
has been in a precipitous decline for
decades this could not have been more
tragically underscored by the testimony
these people are giving to the co
inquiry as we speak now to be fair to
him Boris Johnson who was described by
his former classmate here on
trigonometry as a man who is not unduly
constrained by principle is an outlier
in a crowd of soulless automatons around
him in that his inexplicable Charisma
compensates somewhat for his above
average ineptitude and unparalleled
deceitfulness in my lifetime a period i
necessarily consider brief we went from
Thatcher and Lawson and Blair and brown
to today's crop of incompetence who is
shockingly devoid of principles backbone
and any sort of moral consistency there
are of course exceptions see this video
I did about s Bran's resignation earlier
at the risk of being accused of
spreading fake news by younger viewers
even the liberal Democrats used to have
leaders of character and significance
Patty ashtown who led the party until
1999 was a polyglot who spoke Mandarin
at interpreter level I used to be a
translator and I can tell you that is
impressive not only that Ashdown was a
royal Marine who later joined the elite
special Boat Service followed by aend
MI6 before entering politics whether you
agreed with him on policy or not few
could deny he was a force to be reckoned
with even Charles Kennedy his
permanently pickled placement was widely
respected and taken seriously and
rightly so what is true of leaders is
equally true of the rest for obvious
reasons the quality of those on the back
benches necessarily predicts the quality
of those who lead their parties like a
football club without an academy a
political party which fails to recruit
train and promote upand cominging Talent
will start to struggle on the pitch
before long it has become all too rare
to see political leaders challenged by
Sayan people from their own side on
matters of principle during the lockdown
period Steve Baker and David Davis did a
good job of forcing the government to
slow down and eventually relent on their
Co extremism but despite rumors of
significant dissent no minister of note
spoke out let alone resigned vaccines
Minister Nadem zahari for example
publicly promised not to introduce
vaccine passports which he described as
discriminatory what did he do when the
government decided to plow ahead with
that very policy a few months later did
he speak out threatened to resign or God
forbid actually resign no instead he
explained the vaccine passports go
against everything he believes in before
pressing ahead with the policy anyway
there was no Robin Cook moment because
there are few Robin Cooks left in
politics so how do we get here in the
words of V the Mas protagonist from via
Vendetta if you're looking for the
guilty you need only look into a mirror
I am of course not accusing Ordinary
People me and you of inventing the
24-hour news cycle of the social media
platforms that followed it it is
undoubtedly these two developments that
have acted as a Civ which sorts the
wheat from the chaff promptly elevating
the latter while sticking the former in
the political waste basket but it is
Ordinary People me and you who watch The
NeverEnding news discuss politics and
social media and vote accordingly it is
for this reason I believe that few big
beasts now inhabit the political zoo of
Westminster I've met talked and spared
with dozens of British politicians from
across the political Spectrum on a range
of radio and TV programs in recent years
they're all surprisingly nice some even
have personalities the fact they
skillfully conceal why the mics are hot
and the cameras are rolling But
whichever side of the political spectrum
they sit on few are impressive a society
which prioritizes submissive adherence
to political correctness and Party
Loyalty over substance and character
will inevitably produce a cadra of
slippery appara whose primary skill set
is following the flittering of public
opinion instead of actually leading at
its core leadership is first and
foremost the ability to persuade
individuals to cease acting in what they
perceive to be their own self-interest
for the good of the group consider what
I believe to be the most pressing
domestic challenge facing modern Britain
the housing crisis while the minutia of
the planning laws the perverse
incentives of the construction industry
and a multitude of other convenient sesh
shows are often cited as the reasons for
this ever growing problem the reality is
much simpler the reason politicians talk
about the housing crisis is that they
know it's a problem the reason they do
nothing about it is that they believe
that solving the problem is political
suicide and you're almost certainly
right why because people who are already
on the housing ladder like me benefit
from continuing increases in the value
of our assets or to be more accurate we
think we benefit because it serves our
selfish short-term interest and it's not
the job of individual homeowners with
busy Lives who face growing fuel costs
and Rising interest rates to think about
what the lack of affordable housing for
young people is doing to the marriage
rate the average age of a firsttime
mother and the huge unpredictable but
likely terrible effects this will have
on society it is the job of leaders to
look at that big picture and to persuade
us to understand that yes not every
policy they will Implement will benefit
us personally right here right now but
that will benefit us as a society
allowing us to keep the unspoken promise
of a prosperous democracy that our
children and grandchildren will live
better lives than we did that is the job
of a leader and we deliberately filter
out anyone who's willing to do it a
couple of quick things before you go
first of all these videos are available
as articles on my substack sometimes
months earlier than they are here so
make sure you head on over there and
subscribe right now secondly let me take
a minute to recommend a longevity
supplement by Verso in our recent
interview with Tim Urban he said we
should be talking about longevity and
Longevity science researchers like the
biologist David Sinclair have recently
made some fascinating discoveries on how
to mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that's why I'm using
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products that hold
the potential to increase your longevity
and one of their products that I take
every day is cell beinging cell beinging
helps combat aging by increasing
something called NAD Plus in your body
now NAD is arguably the most important
molecule in your body high NAD levels
improve your metabolism repair damage
DNA and increase energy production in
your brain immune system and muscles but
as you grow old your body's NAD levels
go down and you can't take NAD as a
supplement because it's too big for your
cells to absorb that's why Verso cellb
contains nmn Resveratrol and TMG these
three molecules work together to
increase NAD plus levels if you want to
read more about this check out the
scientific research Linked In the
description of this video plus Verso
publishes third party testing on every
batch of its product to guarantee that
you're getting exactly what you're
paying for so if you want to join me you
can get 15% off by going to
v.o that's
v.o and use our code trigger to save 15%
of your order and if you enjoyed this
check out this video where I explain why
the world makes less and less sense
every
[Music]
year